Up until now, we have
been studying the motion
of point-like objects.
In this module, we
are going to consider
the motion of extended
objects, specifically
objects that are rigid bodies.
By rigid, we mean
that the distance
between any two points on the
object always stays the same.
In other words, the
shape of a rigid body
does not change or deform.
There is a useful relation
known as Chasles' theorem that
states that the
general arbitrarily
complicated displacement
of a rigid body
can be broken up into
two parts-- first,
the translational motion
of its center of mass,
and second, the pure
rotation of the object
about its center of mass.
We already know how
to analyze the center
of mass translational
motion through our study
of point-like objects.
This week, we will consider
the rotational motion
of rigid bodies, once
again distinguishing
between kinematics, a geometric
description of the motion,
and dynamics, the
underlying cause of changes
in the rotational motion.
On a microscopic level, we can
think of an extended rigid body
as made up of a
very large number
of small point-like pieces
all attached together.
For rotation about a fixed axis
through the center of mass,
each little piece
will move in a circle
about the rotational axis.
The radius of the
circle will vary
depending upon
where in the object,
that particular piece sits.
However, because all
of these small pieces
are moving collectively as
part of a single rigid body,
they will all have the same
angular velocity and angular
acceleration at
any given instant.
This gives us a way to specify
the kinematics or geometrical
description of
rotational motion using
the vector quantities of
angular velocity and angular
acceleration.
We will also consider the
dynamics of rotational motion.
We will see that an
applied external force
is able to change the rotational
motion of a rigid body,
depending upon exactly where on
the body the force is applied.
This leads directly to
the concept of torque,
a vector quantity
that represents
a sort of rotational force.
Finally, we will see that
we can link the kinematics
and dynamics of
rotational motion
through a rotational equation
of motion, analogous to the role
that Newton's second law plays
for translational motion.
This relation states that
the angular acceleration
is proportional to
the applied torque
and also depends upon how
the mass of the object
is distributed.